If we pop up a level you can make a
similar argument here which you sort of
made when you asked me that question,
all right.
You asked me the question before
we start the quiz which is,
well if I want to eat a big dot, I need
to avoid the ghosts along the way.
So maybe eating a big
dot eating a dot is
really requires that I
know almost everything.
Except, in the worst case, eating a big
dot doesn't require that over the little
dots are, even if I need to worry
about where the ghosts are and
whether they're scared or not.
Although, if I know where
the dots are then I might
choose to eat the big dots in such a way
that eat a bunch of little dots as well.
But this is really a kind of,
this points out two things.
One, it sort of points out that
if my options are not written in
exactly the right way, then I may not
be able to find an optimum policy,
we'll talk about that in just a moment.
But, if I worry about that,
then all of these options have
to solve every single problem.
And I kind of get nothing out of it.
I don't get a big win by even thinking
about it in terms of options because
effectively, I'm just trying
to solve the entire problem.
The whole point of abstraction, it's
a kind of the Software Engineering and
Computing sense and here we are using
it, is that in part it allows you to do
an abstraction not just over time,
it allows you to do state abstraction.
And other kinds of abstraction.
So, what do I mean by
state abstraction here?
Well, if you look at the big dot case,
if I don't have to worry
about where the dots are,
never mind where the ghosts and
whether they're scared or not.
That means that if I needed to learn
this policy, if I needed to figure out
how to most optimally solve
the problem of eating dots.
I can actually ignore large
parts of the state space.
What happens if I can ignore large
parts of the state space, Michael?
>> Then you can solve
the problems more efficiently.
>> Right in the very beginning we said
the thing that made reinforcement
learning hard is that as the number of
states grew, the problem became more and
more difficult, it was sort of super
linear in the number of states.
So if I can avoid whole features of
the states, that is I can collapse
states that are otherwise different
as if they were single state
where the dots are don't matter, then
the problem of learning this policy,
learning this option
actually becomes easier.
Both from a planning point of view and
from a learning point of view.
>> So
it's if the state space gets smaller?
>> Right.
So
temporal abstraction doesn't
just buys temple abstraction.
It buys a state abstraction.
At least if we can divide
the world up appropriate.
>> Neat.
Okay.
I mean is there a guarantee
that we can always do that?
>> No.
There's not a guarantee that we
can always do that.
>> In the kinds of problems that people
can solve maybe it's pretty common
because people don't have infinite
computational resources either.
>> Right.
And in practice,
I mean, if you just even think about
the way you were describing things,
you sort of ignore large parts
of what's going on around you
in order to solve the problem, right?
We do these kinds of
things all the time.
It had better be the case that we can
ignore large parts of the state space
with otherwise,
we're in trouble it's going to very
difficult to move around in the world.
I mean first off, the world upon DP so
[LAUGH] we're ignoring large
parts of this database anyway.
But beyond that,
I'm in this room talking to you there
are things going on outside I can't see.
By and large I can mostly ignore them
at least for short periods of time.
And we just have to hope in the real
world that the parts of the state space
that might matter such as
I don't know a polar bear,
the location of the closest polar bear.
It will be announced to me
when that becomes relevant.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I can start paying attention to it,
in which case I'm going to stop worrying
about eating my big dots which is what
I call teaching this class and instead
start avoiding ghosts which is what
I call running away from polar bears.